to give you a picture of how amazing
spanner is let's start at the beginning
just creating the database those of you
who've actually tried to deploy a multi
region database that's highly scalable
highly reliable and highly reliant know
that there's like a zillion steps you've
got to configure machines
you got to set up replication you got to
worry about failover you got sharding
what happens if I have Network issues
and then there's the operational side of
just keeping this thing running having
to have whole staffs of people who do
nothing but take care of machinery with
clouds banner we turn that into one
machine Roberts going to bring up the
the dialog to do that he names the
instance he chooses whether he wants it
to be a single or a multi regional
database and then he says how many nodes
and in this case he picks 42 because
that's always the right answer so that's
it we've now created a multi regional
database that has amazing capabilities
but that's getting started let's look at
spanner in an actual real-world scale
example imagine you're a ticket seller
you want to sell tickets to events
worldwide to customers worldwide now
obviously it's pretty important that you
sell a ticket once and only once right
and it's also pretty important that
customers get a good performance
experience wherever in the world they
are buying their tickets in this example
we've deployed cloud spanner into three
Google regions US Europe and Asia all
connected by that private network that
doors told you about we're also running
workloads that emulate customers buying
billions of tickets in this case we're
selling at about half a million tickets
per minute through the system all
through a system that is maintaining
consistent version snapshots full acid
support for transactions full strong
consistency that's the power of spanner
as a distributed base as a distributed
database our customers get a low latency
experience we get good old traditional
sequel consistency now to prove that
this really is a database of some size
let me show you the schema behind this
database you can see it actually is a
sequel database
there's columns that are joined together
and if you look at that ticket date of
table it has 3 billion rows in it so
while we're doing this in
we're running all this traffic against
the real sequel database in fact we can
actually run sequel queries against that
database while it's being hammered with
all that traffic here we have a query
and if you look at the bottom part of
the where clause you see that we're
looking for tickets in the US that are
still available as of 10:00 p.m. and how
many seats they have so these are our
top five events with unsold tickets that
what's important here's what you don't
see what's remarkable is how
unremarkable this sequel looks if you've
deployed a sharding system your sequel
is a mess because you're trying to have
to do joins across multiple shards of
your database in fact it's probably not
even human writable sequel that when you
use those systems spanner takes care of
all that but you know real world
applications aren't static they change
over time what happens when your needs
change well first of all spanner lets
you make transactionally consistent
schema updates with no downtime which is
critically important when you're running
systems that your business depends on
and what happens if you get a wonderful
success and your needs grow well with
the traditional sequel database you
better put a Pio in for a brand new
server you better figure out how to
reconfigure the new server you better
figure out how to migrate the data you
better figure out how to do cutover or
if I'm doing scale out well now I've got
to add a whole new complex middleware
layer that's incredibly difficult to
maintain and even that takes time and
adds operational risk in cloud spanner
Roberts going to go back to the console
and show you how we add capacity to a
spanner database we simply go from 70
nodes to 99 nodes that's it we've scaled
out that's the power of a horizontally
scalable sequel database
[Applause]
and of course since we use spanner so
much internally we made sure it handles
large database robert's going to switch
over to the monitoring console here and
what i want you to look at is that graph
on the bottom left we've been running
this whole demo against an 80 terabyte
database and if you look at the top
right graph when we loaded the data in
we loaded the data at an average of 800
megabytes per second and we peaked at
about a gig per second of loading data
that's amazing that's crazy fast
so that's cloud spanner you create a
highly reliable performant fully managed
multi-region database in seconds cloud
spanner is sequel you get
interoperability in the power of sequel
queries you get acid transactions plus
you get advanced features like
on-the-fly schema changes cloud spanners
fully managed we never had to worry
about setting up replication sharding
failover the system actually even Tunes
itself automatically over time so as you
use it it learns your query patterns and
it optimizes its own performance
characteristics and cloud spanner is
built for scale we've been running our
largest production systems on this for
years so with that I'll turn it back
over to orders for a little bit more the
keynote Thanks